here's what would happen if we went
looking for Life on Mars Mars has a
similar geological path to Earth so
looking underground could be a great
place to start to find rock samples that
might show signs of ancient life NASA's
perseverance Rover uses an array of
lasers called a super cam one of the
lasers heats the rock sample and
vaporizes it this creates a plasma that
can be analyzed to understand its
Elemental composition if the super cam
detects organic molecules or high
concentrations of elements like nitrogen
or phosphorus well then the Rover will
head over to take a closer look it'll
scan the soil in great detail to detect
any organic material hiding in the dirt
if perseverance's mission is successful
the discovery of ancient Life on Mars
who would be as groundbreaking as the
discovery of DNA but not finding any
sign of Life leaves even more questions
is Earth truly special are we alone out
here in space well